-Another great thing about
the new "SNL" season´s
the new writers, new cast
members.
Do you, reflecting back on
your early days on the show,
what was your first week like?
-My -- I have no idea.
I feel like I don´t remember
my first year.
-Yeah.
-It was all --
I was in shock the entire time.
The only thing I do remember is,
I was standing under
the bleachers with Aidy
when Don Pardo announced
our names, and it was like,
"Oh, now it´s real."
-Yeah.
-If I´m in the credits...
-No, right.
Once you´re in the credits,
they have to give you a check.
-Even if I´m not in the show,
I´m in the damn credits.
-Yeah.
-They give you that giant check.
Or -- It´s this big.
-Yeah, that´s great.
You´ve got to go
to your bank and say,
"I need to cash my ´SNL´ check."
-Lorne goes with me, yeah,
he gives it to you.
-And are you excited --
You play Melania
on the show, beautifully.
-Oh, thank you.
-Do you --
Have you been watching
her over the summer?
Are you looking forward
to playing her?
-She had, I think, top three
Melania moments over the summer.
She had, like, really hot hits
over the summer.
-She crushed it
with some moments?
-She crushed at
a lot of silent moments,
like Melania´s silent
is just -- She´s so good.
And all of the hand things.
I mean, she´s like a little cat.
Like, remember
the hand-swatting?
-Oh, when he tried
to take her hand.
-Yeah, and she does it all
with such grace.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-And doesn´t ever fall.
It just like --
It looks like
it´s choreographed, almost.
And then she took
her somber moment.
That was my favorite picture,
was at the Wailing Wall,
and she´s in these red,
gorgeous heels, and, like,
this white suit,
and really taking her moment,
the sacred moment at the wall.
It was like, "Yeah.
I get you, girl."
[ Laughter ]
I can´t wait until there are
so many drag Melania Trumps.
-Oh, yeah.
I didn´t even think about that,
but that will be right up.
-Oh, I´m thinking about it.
That´s all I´m thinking about.
-Well, there´s a lot
of wonderful two-shots
of, you know,
he´s gesticulating,
and being sort of blow-hardy,
and she´s just aviators.
-She´s thinking about bullying.
-Yeah, oh, right.
That´s her cause, is bullying.
-Yeah.
-Do you think she´s been
an effective champion
for the anti-bullying movement?
-As a real answer,
obviously, no.
-Yeah.
-Not in any -- on any Earth,
on any planet, but I´m going to
go ahead and say yes anyway,
´cause she´s --
That´s her thing.
-Yeah.
Do you think in the middle
of the night she ever leans over
to Donald and comes up with...
-She says like,
[ As Melania ] "I hate bullies."
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Normal voice ] That´s her.
That´s her speech.
-She like, shakes him awake -- "
[ As Melania ] Donald,
do you think it´s good?
I hate bullies.
Is good tweet?
[ Normal voice ]
Like she writes her own tweets.
[ Light laughter ]
-You --
So, you were at Second City.
You were an improviser
in Chicago.
Were you --
Did you kind of get
into Second City right away,
or were you doing improv shows
before that?
-So, when I was taking classes,
there would be like a couple
of the paid shows that we did
were all weird, and I did one
with my friend Paul.
It was -- It was like
a fashion show, I think,
but they wanted us to do improv.
-That´s never a good idea.
-It was terrible.
-Yeah.
-And it was like no one --
No one was even listening,
and we just had to keep going,
which was awful.
And then finally when we got
to leave the stage,
there was no backstage
so we were trapped.
So we had to then go back on
to the stage to exit,
and at that point,
I just stood by the garbage can
and pretended to be
a garbage attendant,
to see if people would
even remember that I had been
on the stage, and if they --
And, like, people that
would assume that´s
a regular thing.
This is so fancy, you can´t
throw your own trash away.
-So you would...
-Give it to that girl
in a giant coat.
-You did child --
You were a child actor.
Well, you were
a stage child actor.
-Yes, exactly.
-What were those
early shows like?
-I did a lot as the
Bailiwick Theater in Chicago.
-Sure.
-And basically --
It was a very,
also, gay theater.
So I was raised by so many
[ Audience member laughs ]
wonderful gays --
that really tickled you.
[ Laughter ]
So, I was raised by all
these amazing gay men,
and I was doing this show,
this family show called
"Christmas Schooner" and it´s
still going now in Chicago,
but the late show that would
come in after us was
"Cyber Queer."
So I was, like, 11 years old,
and would skip off stage,
and there was just,
like, a giant man
in little Speedo underpants
that´s like, "Hey, sweetie,
can I have my makeup table?"
"Sure ´Cyber queer´!"
[ Laughter ]
-Well, it must have been
a nice education, though.
-It was --
Oh, I wouldn´t trade it
for the world.
It really made me the gay man --
the cyber queer that I am today.
-Well, we´re lucky to have you.